two spheres have equations uh
absolute value of r equals three and
then absolute value of you've got a
shifted sphere for the second one equals
four part a explain why the circle of
intersection of the two spheres is
parallel to the x y plane now
emmanuel and i were just having a
conversation uh
moments ago about how tricky it is to
try and justify this
with a diagram in three dimensions
especially when the question itself
see that's a three-dimensional question
do you see that it's like the x-y plane
i've got a plane here
and i need to be parallel to that in
three dimensions right
so i am going to use a 2d diagram but
the 2d diagram alone
not going to be sufficient okay so let
me see if i can work this through
i know a few things about this is the
wrong color i know a few things about
these two spheres
right from their equations i can read
off two key pieces of information
the two pieces of information that
define every circle every sphere
what can you tell me i can tell the
center
and the radius if you haven't drawn a
diagram yet go ahead and draw one
and where would we put these two pieces
of information that would be useful to
me
well let's call this the this is the
smaller circle right so what's its
center origin it's the origin so
um i called my previous one like a and b
right but this time i'm going to call
this
o for origin and i'll write that as 0 0
0.
what's my other center zero zero five
uh let's call this one a because i
haven't used that yet
all right now i'm trying to show that
the
circle of intersection which on here
where
is this circle of intersection i'm
looking at it in cross section
right so i guess it would be like i had
here
right it's like you're looking onto it
side on right
so it would be here there's my circle of
intersection it's just
infinitesimally thin because i'm looking
at it side on right i want to show that
that thing is
parallel to the x y plane i didn't even
have a plane here or a 3d coordinate
system for that matter right
how would i go about showing this think
with me
about the information that we know and
how it relates to the xy plane
if you have a look closely i've got
you might think i've chosen a bad marker
for this but i promise it's on purpose
i've got this line joining my two
centers
right it's not an arbitrary line because
of the particular coordinates of my
particular centers of my particular
spheres
this is actually a special line in the
3d coordinate system
because you go from in x zero
to zero no change in y you go from zero
to zero no change you only change
in the z direction this makes sense so
therefore
can anyone tell me what special line
this is this is the z-axis
isn't it this is the z-axis
so what i have in fact and i would have
used the word perpendicular if i were in
two dimensions
right if i had say an interval and a
line
lines and intervals two dimensional can
be perpendicular this actually
represents a circle
doesn't it right so instead of saying
it's perpendicular i would say
it's orthogonal
this circle of intersection is
orthogonal to the z-axis
right that's so important i'm going to
write this down because this is the
conversation i was having with a manual
right
the circle of intersection
is orthogonal and this is why we
introduced this word rather than just
staying with perpendicular even though
it's very useful
it's a it's a surface isn't it it's
at right angles to the z-axis
oops but since the z-axis
is itself orthogonal to the x-y plane
think about how we normally draw this
right
here's the uh which way do we normally
do it here's the x-y plane that we're
looking
down at right and there goes the z
axis perpendicular to this x y plane
that we can see here right so literally
the circle of detection is orthogonal
to the z axis
which is orthogonal
to the xy plane
this is pretty much it this is my
reasoning right
this diagram here is just to help you i
haven't actually put the spheres on
there
right but you can see this is the
relationship that i'm after and shows
that's my explanation i would find it
very difficult to award anything which
didn't use words
to try and get at that um keyword
so this part a for me okay i've got that
right relationship
then how do i how's that going to help
me to determine the center and radius
of the circle of intersection find the
center and radius
of this circle here okay
anyone want to suggest to me some
information i can put onto this diagram
that might be useful calvin
um
okay so you're talking about uh oh right
i see
you already know don't you what the x
and y coordinates are here
since we're moving along the z axis uh
let's call this something like p
right i'm going to have no change in x
and no change in y
and then i have i don't know some change
in z
so really that's all i need to find so
far so good
that's helpful what other information in
the question have i not used yet
or not put onto my diagram anyway
the radii right now there's a couple of
different places actually there's
infinitely many places that i could
place the radii what are they three and
four
right where might be places that are
useful to me
being that i could put them anywhere say
it again
ah now i could go across the z axis so i
guess that would be three
and then that would be four do you agree
now that wouldn't be wrong the only
problem is because of this overlapping
thing right
it starts to become confusing about well
how much of the three is overlapping
with how much of the four
infinite set of places we could go i'm
going to suggest maybe
here is going to be
useful to me three
and four now the reason i know this is
because
this three and this four are not
accidentally chosen
numbers because you can see they form a
bit of a triangle here don't they
this is why i had to choose such a dead
marker from before so i can draw over it
i've got a triangle there please tell me
what kind of triangle it's going to be
it's going to be right angled right it's
going to be right angled because
i already knew that this distance was 5.
do you see that i got that from the
coordinates
so bam right angle okay
now let me just pause for a moment
remembering that all we're really after
is z
here right well actually to find the
center we'll have to find the radius in
a second okay
so all i need to do is find say this
distance here that in fact is the
distance
z what information or what knowledge or
skills do we have
access to that might help us find that
teeny tiny distance said let me
highlight it a little more for you
this is the distance i'm after i suggest
that that red distance there
is z how would we find it
oh wow i could go straight to projection
couldn't i because you're like oh
i see this vector is casting a shadow
onto this vector
that'd be a really nice way to do it
because that's exactly what projection
does
the only problem i have with that it's a
good method is that projection relies on
what information what do i need to put
into my projection formulas
i need some direction vectors don't i in
this particular question
i'm i have i have this direction vector
yes
i do not have this one i just kind of
arbitrarily drew it right so it's a good
method
if i had different information what do
you reckon john assuming this plane
we're looking at
is the x that plane or the y z plane so
that one of the
other corners is equal to zero therefore
the radius of the circle that we're
trying to find is either the white
corner or the x corner
of the one of the intersection points
one of these ones
yeah that way we have set squared plus
radius squared equals the three squared
and one
minus that squared plus right and then
we have
two simultaneous equations okay very
good just in case you didn't quite
follow that right
because we've drawn this in cross
section right what we can imagine is
well not what we can imagine what we are
in fact looking at is one of those
orthogonal uh coordinate planes right
next
xy et cetera right so as a consequence
of looking at
one particular plane you can consider
one of the
coordinates there's always to be zero
right does that make sense on say the x
y
plane the x y plane the flat one z is
always zero
because it's flat down you can't you
can't come off and have some other
values
n right so once you've got one of them
being zero you've turned this from a
three variable
problem into a two variable problem and
that's much more easy to handle
now these methods would both work with
the right information we could by the
way
using giuu's method we can't actually
find what that direction vector is it's
totally doable right
however remember at the start of this um
for that other question i loved vern's
method because it was so lazy i have a
method that will beat the pants off of
all of you
in its laziness i think we could go back
to
late year eight early year nine
to solve this question right yeah yeah
remember we saw these right
angles in here right all these right
angles um what that means is because you
have a right angle here
and a right angle here and you've got
all these nested triangles
within each other if for example i were
to mark in i don't even
need to know how big it is but if i were
to mark in that theta
angle there do you see
that this angle theta is in this little
triangle over here with z in it
this theta is also in this three four
five triangle
it's both got theta they've both got a
right angle what kind of triangles are
what's the relationship between them
they're similar triangles right right
just because of time i'm just going to
show you how it plays
out because the important thing here is
don't use an overpowered tool
if you have access to an easier one that
will do the same job so you can see i've
set up
my triangles in here i've just i've
realized in my own working i'm like whoa
too much stuff flying around here
so you can see i've i've completely
abandoned the spheres in this top
diagram so that makes sense
once i've got the right information
there you can even see the same theta
that i drew in the corner
because we're in extension two we can
use that phrase we so enjoy
by inspection don't need to worry about
like you don't need to find the angles
they're there
they are equiangular that's all i need
the only tricky thing is you need to
identify which
sides correspond to which sides you can
see in the scheme that i've got here
i've got o and
a like i did here i named it c i forgot
the n into c doesn't matter
do you remember when we first introduced
similar triangles to you
maybe your teachers were quite finicky
about how you ordered
the letters of the vertices for the
different
corners of the triangle right we said
make sure you match them up
you don't know why we tell you to match
them up it's to make
this next step really easy i'm comparing
sides let me just zoom out a little bit
sides oc that's my z that i'm after
right with side o b up there
right because i know this side i have no
idea what this altitude is equal to
it's an unknown length i'm going to find
it later okay if i'm comparing oc and ob
have a look at my order of my letters
right
oh whoops o c
that's the first and the third ones that
corresponds to o
and b in the other triangles that make
sense i did all the ordering
up in this line so oc here corresponds
to ob
here makes sense and then in the same
way ob it's the first two
here will correspond to the first two
here so it's ob
on the right hand triangle once you've
done that it's quite trivial actually to
go ahead
and work out the coordinates look ma
didn't even use any vectors
right that's just the center
we find z it's 9 over five so that's
this value here
how do we then get to radius
where is the radius even on this diagram
it's the yeah isn't isn't this this
altitude that i said we didn't know the
length of
before now there's lots of fancy ways to
do this but
you know for me once shame on me for me
twice shame on you
or the other way around all i have to do
is just a little bit more
similar triangles because i have all the
stuff that i need here you just need to
match up
the different sides so that makes sense
and then 12 on 5 is
this length here even a sense check on a
decent diagram will show you that what's
12 on 5.
two and two fifths looks pretty good to
me
okay